schauen wir auf ein kleines leben ist
eben erst begonnen hat und sofort brutal
ausgelöscht wurde wir schauen auf die
kleine kira dieses kleine rosige baby
drei monate alt hier in den armen ihrer
mama valeria diese arme dieser hand die
konnte kira nicht schützen kira und ihre
mama sterben putins raketen schlagen in
ihr wohnhaus in odessa ein auch oma
ludmilla hier zu sehen mit kira auf dem
arm ist tot der papa hier mit dem baby
auf dem arm der war kurz einkaufen und
kam zurück drei generationen sind tot
drei generationen frauen wir sehen hier
die glücklichen momenten dieses paares
der papa dells alleine zurückbleibt die
sich gemeinsam so sehr gefreut haben auf
dieses baby auf die kleine kira denn so
sieht das wohnhaus aus der vater juri
hat es ganz kurz verlassen wir zeigen
ihnen gleich das wohnhaus das sieht man
es war aber kurz weg und schon schlucken
hier in odessa die rakete ein und genau
in der wohnung ist es glaube ich gar
nicht so ein großes loch in im haus ist
traf genau ihr
apartment ihre wohnung und jetzt muss
kiraz papa juri abschied nehmen drei
särge vor ihm ein ganz kleiner für sein
baby für seine kira und für seine große
liebe valeria und oma ludmilla es ist
ein großer gottesdienst zu dem viele
menschen gekommen sind um abschied zu
nehmen immer wieder hat er sich
schluchzend auf kiras sarg geworfen in
der hand hatte er die ganze zeit ein
kuscheltier von seiner tochter mich
steht fast ganz odessa jetzt bei in
dieser schrecklichen stunde erfragte in
dieser situation wir sehen hier seine
mutter neben ihnen seine schwester neben
ihm und die särge er fragte immer wieder
warum ich warum muss mir das passieren
putins raketen die eine ganze generation
ausgelöscht haben die ein papa alleine
zurückgelassen haben und genau wegen
solcher opfer kleinen opfer wegen
solcher schicksale wegen solcher
unglaublichen geschichten gibt es
klartext jetzt formal clooney vor den
vereinten nationen die frau von george
clooney
menschenrechtsanwälten sie fordert putin
zur verantwortung zu ziehen ganz worte
hat sie gefunden die frau des hollywood
stars vor dem un-sicherheitsrat in new
york schauen sie das war ihr auftrag
auftritt dort und sie hat putins gewalt
dort in der ukraine mit klaren worten
gegeißelt wollten wir ihnen an dieser
stelle zeigen es war ein beeindruckender
auftritt und klare worte hier sehen wir
sehen und hören dass auch wir hören doch
mal ganze
fdp trainings für die
branche slomka minoretti
trainingscamp in also putins krieg ist
so ungeheuerlich sagte maloney und vor
allen dingen sagen sie es hat immer
wieder warnungen gegeben wir haben bei
solchen der ganze westen bei solchen
kriegsverbrechen viel zu lange
hingeschaut weggeschaut und das ist eben
das ergebnis man weiß als diktator dass
man sich so etwas erlauben kann ohne
dass die welt reagiert und das ist das
ergebnis das sagt marc juni vor den
fallen im netz